[Music]  what we know is exercise is the single  biggest elixir for brain health  um  and it's amazing how you know how much  more powerful it appears to be than  nutrition  even sleep and those things are very  important but exercise is in a league of  its own and we we studied this question  extensively about eight years ago and i  didn't  i initially just refused to believe this  was the answer because it seemed too  simplistic i thought there had to be  something more powerful but as important  as sleep nutrition are exercise kind of  takes the cake  and i suspect it's because it impacts so  many systems glucose disposal insulin  sensitivity  inflammation  it produces growth factors for neurons  bdnf  so  the most important thing they can do for  their brain health is to exercise that's  where you get into the hast if you could  do three hours a week that's great if  you can do seven hours a week it's even  better